stop the presses gang got a special
announcement the middle class famous
tour is in full effect hey your tickets
me the bald one the long hair we're
coming to a city near you bring the
squad out it's a great way to introduce
people to the show you get to see some
stand-up you get to play a little ayg
with me in the gipperino it's a good
time hit me out yeah guys we're going to
be in atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rose man guys it's a great
time can't wait to see you out there get
your tickies now yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grow up to be classy
yeah or they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day down here in
auntie's basement i saw her leaving
today yeah in handcuffs
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is my best pal in the
whole wide world i love you buddy give
it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always make sure
you rate view subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube uh as you
know those numbers are true to roof
[ __ ] cooking over there on youtube
and uh obviously i have to mention the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com sign up you get bonus
content we do a whole nother podcast on
there called hard feelings you get live
streams the whole nine yards check it
the [ __ ] out yes sir and how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good you know him you love him
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what up dudes about to get some
text from the in-laws off this one let's
go dude
got a big one in here hey lion gang
because we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time he is
an extremely funny extremely successful
stand-up comedian podcaster actor and
international sensation
he is one of the coaches
he is one of the co-creators and stars
of the worldwide juggernaut that is
impractical joker they have sold out
theaters and arenas all over the world
they have their own crews skye's got his
own navy look the [ __ ] out
also the co-host of the amazing taste
buds podcast but the big question about
his mind today is he garbage i already
mentioned the cruise but let's do it
anyway
give it up for the one the only salvo
everybody
thank you guys thank you guys for having
me staten island kid made good look at
that that's right that's right look at
you like the wu-tang clan in here that's
right suburbs blue collar i'm with you
what is it what does it give me the
origin story you grew up on staten
island tell us the whole deal
uh yeah i grew up on staten island and
that's pretty much the deal
that was a very staten island answer
yeah
you were talking to the nypd i was home
i was on
[Laughter]
i was born and raised there uh hopped
around a bunch moved a bunch when i was
little i went to catholic school i
actually went to catholic school grammar
school high school and college really
yeah i mean college was saint john's but
it was a catholic college st john's
going to have to take new york thing to
do get to st john it was like monsignor
farrell old boys catholic uh and then i
went to st joseph's parochial school
that was a little neighborhood like
catholic school uh-huh that's onstage
they're all on stat last few minutes
from yeah so you would take like the the
regular bus to school or right this
summer high school i took the bus yeah
the regular bus regular bus that's tough
yeah it's not a new york thing there was
a
staten island has one train it's above
ground and it has one line it goes to
the end and back and if you if you were
able to get to one of those train
stations you could hop on that because
the train we had a station at the high
school so but it would take a little
extra leg work because you walked like
20 minutes to get to that but then it
was smooth sailing once you're on it
yeah the bus was a little bit more seedy
yeah new york buses are nothing to
nothing to play with yeah and that's
that's that's early 90s yeah that's
early 90s yeah that was you were down
with opp or you weren't
what about your mom and dad what did
they do for a living brothers and
sisters
absolutely so my dad was a sanitation
man okay classic new staten island job
yes it is good bennies yes nice yes
growing up he had a bunch of jobs i
don't mean that
[Laughter]
this guy's wearing a wire every time i
see a tell
i i know him for years but i don't know
very very well like anybody else and he
always just assumed because i'm look i'm
half italian but i'm from staten island
my name is sal everyone always just
stereotypes me right away yeah he always
is like every time he digs i just want
to talk sopranos
he's like they're making a sopranos
movie you should audition
or he'll be like oh yeah and he'll just
ask me mafia questions and i'm like man
i just scratched a little more of the
surface with me david please i'm not
that god i also love when he thinks you
need to play goon number three
[Laughter]
despite that too sometimes like he calls
me saul
i'm saul the mafia guy to him i guess
i don't know i never have the heart to
correct him
yeah with guys like that you're like oh
okay i'm sorry i mean yeah i think if
i'm in front of him if he's near me and
someone's like hey i'm bill i'm like hey
soul volcano
i don't know
his nickname in the mod i
his nickname in the mob is the boyle
they call him the moyle
what's the other half you said half
italian half um cuban puerto rican and a
little bit of actual spanish okay yeah
this guy's got it all so my smoothie
right there yeah
that's a staten island smoothie
holy [ __ ] give me the soul volcano
and who's whose sides are those like
who's who's italian my dad your dad's
italian and your mom is cuban puerto
rican a little
and brothers and sisters i have three
sisters okay um all for
all all of them have three different
moms
okay okay so i have two this is why we
played that game
[Laughter]
my dad married when he was young like
17. okay and was married for a while um
my first sister uh my sister is from
that marriage and me and my sister
another sister from my mom's and then my
dad is married to my stepmom for almost
40 years now that's my third sister so
they got to so your mom and dad got
divorced did your mom realize
she did for like four years okay yeah
from 90 to 94 but that didn't take
nobody got rid of nobody like i thought
it was a great way to explain a marriage
it didn't take
it was a lap band
now we rejected
so are they are they both from staten
island your mom and dad um well my mom
was born in brooklyn but lived here from
a young and sat down from a young age
okay and my dad uh yes that island yeah
and was there your extended family out
there too extended yeah so so so okay so
my mom how italian are we talking that's
what i want to know how italian okay so
my dad's side very very italian okay so
his entire family on the same block
wow yeah i'm talking aunts uncles
cousins his mother his father everything
a block
and maybe maybe like another well i mean
it was all within like you could shout
from the window type of deal that's
awesome they had chickens and i'm sure
they got haley yeah live chickens yeah
they had the coop yeah
sally get over here and kill him no they
actually had a case of rubber chickens
and that's kind of why i became a
comedian big pranksters as [ __ ]
chickens i'm like no the philly's mascot
was that was he a chicken
[Laughter]
of course of course yeah would you do
the seven fishes on christmas uh now i
mean if part of the family would we
wouldn't but we did have a big meal okay
yeah i think it was more like i was
probably seven fish adverse at that age
when you guys do thanksgiving is there
italian cuisine involved in that meal or
is it straight
classic
there's a little manicotti on the table
the main is classic but there's always a
song
to valet hit him winning
run in the garage and eat some goblet
hole real quick
get your head on straight
all right you went to st john's yeah st
john's for college
uh majored in finance i have a
bachelor's degree in finance all right
wow compared to books yeah yeah yeah
um were you a good student yeah i was a
good student i got a i got a scholarship
to college for academic uh yeah it was
it was like three quarters
i gotta admit i guess that wasn't a full
what was it what was the gpa
uh well once i got in into college it
was like between three and three five i
wasn't anything crazy in high school
though uh like 90s really yeah and
what'd you get in your sats do you
remember yeah i got uh it was 11.90
yeah ready 650 and 540. yeah i don't
remember 650 on the master because we
got people in here they're like i'm not
sure it's like you [ __ ] know what you
got i haven't thought of it in a while
but i do i always remembered it yeah any
sports growing up yeah not good but like
uh
in grammar school i played on uh
basketball and baseball but
again not good um
we we we didn't have sports and then
they got sports while i was there oh
that's a tough one
[Laughter]
i've never seen a basketball before yeah
so like one week they're like we have
basketball now
and then i was like oh i i shoot
basketball by my house like i'll go and
then like everybody was better than me
and so i got the last person so it was
sixth grade i think and there was seven
seventh grade seventh eighth graders
made varsity and then the rest went to
jv and i was like the last one cut
from varsity but i wasn't good okay but
i ended up being the best on jv again
not good there you go owen 14.
my friend's mom
uh like was our coach never coached
basketball in her life wait a minute i'm
sorry your friend's mom was the
basketball coach yeah
yeah they were just like who wants to go
yeah
who's got afternoons free she had just
gotten laid off
so we were owen 14 out i have okay so
i i was the mvp that we had we still had
an awards dinner at the end of the year
oh my god in the mvp of an oh and
i i i got i have the trophies to this
day i had 16 points on the season
[Laughter]
14 games
14 games
okay we never scored only the last game
of the season at halftime we were up and
we couldn't we didn't even know we
looked up and someone went holy [ __ ]
we're winning
the first game we were like are we going
to be good i don't know and then we're
like well what if we what if we face a
team that like has much more experience
than us
every team the first team we played was
from like a more urban area and the
entire team was african-american entire
team there was one kid on the team that
was at least six foot two or three and
we were in sixth or seventh grade yeah
and he
he looked me in the eye because you got
to cyo early and you did practice drills
he looked me in the eye he moonwalked
backward as he dribbled and then did a
no-look layup and i was like we're in
trouble we lost we lost 44 nothing
i didn't even score that
we lost couldn't even score against them
[Laughter]
i had a single single in a game
i just picture all you kids out there in
like in like suits and dress shoes and
[ __ ] like that and then and then at the
end of that game you always have to line
up and you like slap hands in the middle
of course and then you went upstairs and
someone was designated to bring like
like uh
uh what do they call that orange like i
see
juice box no caprice
there we go and like chips and then you
go upstairs
the parents were going wild in the
stands because their team was in
basketball had a shutout so afterwards
they were they were unmerciful when we
were lining up the parents stormed
they stormed the court and as they were
lining up they were next to their
children and they just started chanting
a song in our faces going 44 zip zip 44
i like it i would have been out there
and they were just and it was just like
we were little children who were like
damn it just i'll never forget i hear it
in my sleep sometimes
44 zip zip 44 zip and they chanted it
from the calf court up to two flights of
steps and into the capri sun room
having panic attacks at nick games
shaking the capri sun they put that song
together pretty quick all in unison i
know i know any trouble when you were a
kid do you get any trouble any fights
anything like that no not really i was a
really good kid that yeah i didn't like
i i did all my i went to school i didn't
cut or my sisters were a different story
how far apart i was going to ask you how
far apart are you from them yes so my
oldest sister who um when she was
younger she moved to the west coast okay
and she still lives there today okay so
my relationship with her is long
distance i go to wisdom all the time
sure i didn't grow up with her so
growing up i was second old so i was the
oldest okay
my other sister is three years younger
my other sister is uh nine years younger
okay so you and you and the one that was
three years you guys kind of mixed in
mingled a little bit as far as like
school in high school yeah we were in
the same grammar school together right
and they got in trouble
she did she she ended up going to public
high school and immediately i mean
immediately got in with her like she
came home with a from the first day and
she had a [ __ ] pack of cigarettes and
my mother found an empty zima in the
bathroom
yeah
yeah she's got good taste yeah those
were big bacon those things were all
right back in the day she like got in
with like i mean not a gang but like
like i would i would joke about it with
her because she was like she had a whole
crew and if somebody messed with
somebody and she had people holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah but not like she
wasn't she's a good kid but she really
like she was cutting right away and she
was hanging out with the wrong crowd
right away i was like
i s i was like no absences
like yeah like that kind of thing yeah
it's good [ __ ] all right all right so
far so far not too bad played uh a
little baseball and then in high school
i played ice hockey you played ice
hockey on the team yeah on the team
that's not bad when did they get that at
the school they had always had a good
team yeah but again i didn't make
varsity
i played the first couple of years uh on
jv and then i tapped out after that and
how about saint john's were you working
while you were in school or anything
what's that what'd you do restaurant guy
right gotta be i started from my first
job was 14 years old at a convenience
store 24 hours nice i was there
overnight
i noticed how i throw in 24 hours like
it's a break
i was like
24 hours
they were open 24 hours you need to
leave it in the blizzard of 94 today you
need some lucy's and some milk you come
by and see me i can straighten me out
started stock boy went to register then
eventually went to delhi for the kelly
was big he definitely made it to delhi
it was huge it was like a 1.50 bump up
yes yeah an hour and then uh so i was
there 149 but in my 19th year when i was
still there i went down the block and
when i started i started delivering
pizza and i eventually passed the baton
to just pizza deliver pizza that was
lucrative yes comparatively really cash
every night yeah because i would make
you know on a great night like 10 to 15
an hour off the books yeah okay which
was unheard of like in the job i came
from i was at 6 25 on the box damn yeah
so you're working your whole life man
that's [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
commendable were you driving when you
were doing delivery yeah what was the
car oh boy it was yours or theirs too
okay so i went through a lot of cars
okay so my first car ever was gifted to
me from my parents at the time my dad
and my stepmom it was their old car oh
they let me use it they put they taped
keys in the birthday card that's pretty
good though i like that was in 1985
buick skyhawk hole
[ __ ]
silver isn't it sky lark no you had a
hawk i had a hawk oh man this guy's
going off book it was silver we called
it quicksilver i named all my cars of
course oh of course uh total that uh i
was going through an intersection and a
a van a plumbing van that was at a red
light thought it turned green
and i was on uh the side of the
expressway like the uh service road i
had some speed there cooking and then i
had bold tires and then he went and i
hit and i slid maybe a hundred feet with
the bowl ties hit into him car went in
like an accordion i swear to god i got
out of the car the back and the front
were right to here the only thing that
didn't get crushed was my seat i just
said that just right it's like a cartoon
and this will buff right out don't worry
my dad knows a guy then um then my dad
then i needed another car so my dad this
is how we shop for a car my dad took me
in his car and we drove we drove up and
down the streets of the neighborhood
just looking for a car that had written
on it like for sale
yeah yeah 1300 obo or best offer yeah
and we got um at that time we got what
was it it was okay so this is why i
needed the car desperately too no no
wait wait that time we got a plymouth
reliant k car i know that brown sure it
was the old driver's ed car yeah they
used to have two steering wheels mine
didn't but those are the ones that i had
i thought you're gonna be driving around
with two steering wheels that'd be
awesome that'd be crazy dude
your boys hitting the brake
it only had am radio so i put a sony
boombox with batteries in the front
bench seat and i would play the boombox
while i drove
same intersection same exact
intersection i was driving the ah where
the car was the other way this was like
a year later a lady made a turn i found
out she was a toll booth collector that
worked at the verrazano bridge that was
right by there she she made a turn and i
slammed it she cut off traffic slammed
into a total that car
okay went to court i won that okay
but did you lose the other one it might
have been owen 14 on the court but i'm
i'm one
another the other one the guy i was a
little bit green in in car as far as car
accidents go i had a marble notebook on
he wrote his name and number one and
then when i went to go talk to somebody
else he ripped it out and when he drove
away i didn't have his contact
information bastards [ __ ] right
to this day if you're listening i just
hope you die
okay let's talk about athletic greens
athletic greens you know them you love
them i use them every single day and
that is not a lie absolutely fantastic
throw it shake it up in the mixer
good for the gut health yep good for the
immunity yeah keeps you going all day
feels great feels great love those
athletic greens best thing about it it's
lifestyle friendly whether you're doing
keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten-free they got you covered
contains less than one gram of sugar no
gmos no nasty chemicals no artificial
anything while still tasting good
take that
uh they have over uh seven thousand five
star reviews recommended by professional
athletes trusted by leading health
health experts the whole nine yards i
was created when the founder experienced
a ton of gut health issues and ended up
on a compliment supplement routine to
recover cost him a hundred dollars a day
that wipes all this out boom just the
ag-1 in a water bottle shake it up
you're good to go there you go uh right
now it's time to reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition especially heading into
cold and flu season
just one scoop of uh one scoop and in
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is go to athletic
greens.com garbage again that's
athleticgreens.com garbage to take
ownership over your health today can't
let's talk about the good people a
ladder love ladder yeah listen folks in
these uncertain times wonky out there
you want to make sure that your family's
taken care of god forbid anything would
happen and ladder can absolutely help a
lot of people get scared off term life
insurance but latter are the guys you
gotta go to yes ladders 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for three million in coverage or
less just a few minutes a phone laptop
to apply ladder smart algorithms work in
real time to find out if you're
instantly approved no need to talk to
anybody on the phone but you can if you
want there you go the best thing is they
don't work on commission so they're not
trying to upsell you just trying to
figure out what's good for you no hidden
fees canceled at any time get a route
full refund if you change your mind in
the first 30 days so go to
ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
yeah
the next lady was uh the next lady she
was completely at full and a guy in a
mazda miata real hip cat
he had what seems to be the problem kid
he had shades on he pulled over i mean
the lady were arguing he pulled over
excuse me i saw the whole thing he gets
out he goes i'm a lawyer he's my card if
you need a witness what i was like whoa
and i just peeled off into the day
and then uh that lady denied it i went
to court with her
the guy showed up
he showed up to be my witness and she
brought a witness what okay and then i
was like she they tried to blame me and
i was like i never saw this woman right
she wasn't there at all and and and then
and then she was like no she was there
she was my witness and then my lawyer uh
whoever was representing me or whatever
went um to the witness what color is his
car and she didn't know and it was like
what they should have thrown isn't that
like [ __ ] johnny cochran who the [ __ ]
was your she should have been like uh
like law and order
she should have gotten in trouble there
but they just like basically
didn't give her any credit
after that i got a job at the pizza
place and i didn't have a car and i
needed one uh-huh so i found another one
for nine hundred dollars a brown chevy
spot to miata
yeah i wish a brown chevy celebrity and
i i got the job and i told them i had a
car already and i didn't i've been
asking for that job for a while because
my two friends deliver pizza and made
sick money yeah so i was like let me get
so i got that i can't went back to my
dad i'm like i gotta get a call within
the next three days i start monday you
[ __ ] crashed three of them
so i get the car to get the temp stuff
whatever whatever it was i think it was
even fake actually to tell you the truth
until i got i think i went to the staten
island plays by its own rules yeah for
you folks out there we just went over
for our first time went to do chrissy
d's podcast and they have the signs
saying like no fake tags for the
brilliant
yeah you got a discount right yeah yeah
yeah we get yeah we got it i was like
i've never seen like a government-issued
sign saying don't counterfeit license
plates or whatever i wanted a little
pizza in that car the first night it was
a monsoon i went to turn on the wipers
they didn't work
so
i can't tell them they don't work
because this is supposed to be my car
i'm supposed to know all about it so i
went and got a [ __ ] twine and i t and
i
i tied it to the windshield wipers and
then i and then i i wrapped it around my
fist and i was driving pulling the
freaking
[Laughter]
i know i was delivering pizza and i
remember i was going to 32 reed avenue
and i was i was i was driving and i was
smoking and i reached down to grab my dr
pepper and when i looked back up
the car had shifted and i was i was
going about 35 miles an hour and i was
three feet from parked cars i slammed
into the parked car it popped over the
curb knocked down a wrought iron friends
went into a front yard of someone and
the bake ziti i had long hair like a
seed he's all over the place i had long
hair like
pizziti my god disease
[Laughter]
oh the zine guys
my head went hit the windshield
shattered i had long hair in college i
had shards of glass all over my hair i
swear to god we got the sauce
yeah looks like your head was cracked
everywhere and i was like stunned i'll
never forget it was a friday because
it's really busy i was stunned and i was
sitting i'm in the weekend
nobody was around and i like when it
happened and i was like stunned and then
moments later the other delivery guy
drove past me and he slowed down he was
in a mustang and he goes sal i'm like go
get pat he was the he was the uh more z
stat my trunk popped open my hockey
equipment was all over the street
i'll never forget the guy whose car it
was was a commuter from the city he got
off the express bus walked across the
street i had baked ziti and glass in my
head the police were there and he walked
over he goes what the [ __ ]
and i just went i didn't mean it
i've had what it looks like since then
though i have not crashed a car
grab a slice out of the back
and sit
what was the name of that pizza place
can i ask you that classic pizza how was
the pizza it was great it was a good
neighborhood nice downtown like
neighborhoods
yeah yeah good food over there yeah it
was good food yeah i know the one uh
there's that one deli that has the pig
in the front the pig's face you know
what i'm talking about fury maybe yeah
that's exactly what it is
yeah this place is nice good good good
good grub over there man we got good
italian deli
as long as sal is not delivering it i'll
order
okay let's do some are you garbage
questions here that is quite the tail i
like it
um
put gum under the table
no
okay
so far that's a new one so good
i did it last night that's what i wanted
really did you wear your house no i was
i did it on saturday night at a
restaurant in uh brooklyn oh my god you
walk away from that not feeling anything
that's insane i had i was drinking i was
about to i was ashamed just ordered a
drink i had gum in my mouth was i
supposed to swallow it napkins swallow
it would you swallow it no but there are
there were other ways out there's
crosstalk there were clothes but you're
painted into a corner here
that's crazy don't ever do that i'm
being judged what's going on here
everything with littering of any kind i
really don't do when i see someone throw
something out of their window in a car
i'll be the guy that pulls up next to me
like what are you doing well i'll i'll
assess the person first
before i decide how i'll start running
sometimes i'm just like can we not or
you know and then sometimes you know
yeah yeah and i don't litter at all but
i mean that's not littering
is it yeah it's a gray area you're right
it's a gray it's not not littering
though at the same time i will tell you
i feel like i've see and feel gum on
surfaces way less than when i was
growing up of course yeah 80s tonight we
were we were talking about littering in
the 80s and 90s was like you'd be
driving down the highway and someone
just throw a whole mcdonald's like it
was it just happened all the time yeah
it was nothing telephone poles we had
telephone poles covered in gum yeah that
was a good thing yeah i remember when i
realized that those black spots on the
sidewalk were gone yeah like holy that's
all gum yeah just all gum
you ever throw your sneakers over the
telephone wire i have
okay that's littering there you go
that's hard
it's quick so is the gum
i made a little shape out of it
staten island banksy over
here uh growing up did you drink milk
with dinner
um
not as uh as long okay but but i'm sure
it's happened like my aunt my aunt uh
insisted on milk instead of like
something else yeah all right well it's
the grocery store your mom went to
growing up a and p amp all right nice
establishment that was i don't know if
they exist anymore you guys know amp amp
got bought by i think by somebody but
like acme or associated or somebody like
that yeah yeah would you guys also do
like uh where'd you get your deli meat
from where are you getting that from
were you getting that from the amp we
were getting it from the amp or the rose
rose bank delhi which was the delhi
right there like a nice town i mean the
corner deli
and what are we talking about what did
you guys do would you do like classic
turkey and ham or were we doing like
italian like mortadelle and all that
stuff i i didn't go crazy we didn't have
you know i i was like ham and cheese
okay i was a ham and cheese baloney
i'm with it what's your for lunch today
i had leftovers
pasta and meatballs leftovers that were
made at the house or you took home
made at the house okay very good made it
my sisters okay yeah how do you i don't
have that that often either i know that
that was a very convenient answer sure
but actually i was running late today
and the only thing i only had time to
heat something up so how do you feel
about if you do go out to dinner will
you take leftovers home with you
absolutely yeah yeah okay oh no waste
good man no waste good i don't waste it
i just finish it there yeah i'll just
eat it i'll finish it there but i'm
bringing it home if it's not okay now
did you have the the leftovers you had
today did you ha you had a dinner at her
house last night
two nights ago so two nights ago you
went over to your sisters for dinner yes
and you're leaving sal take some
meatballs way too much okay yeah yeah
yeah you brought it home and i was
partially my fault i i always say make
more and have extra never run out sure
i'm like having a super bowl gathering
right now too i'm going over this with
my girl because she always wants to
order less than i think i'm like she
always says like don't it's gonna be
wasteful i'm like we'll send people home
with food the last thing i want is
someone to be hungry and not have any
more food
that's the foley family's biggest fear
and source of arguments anxiety because
my parents have people over all the time
in the summer to go to the pool and it's
just hey you should there's aaron is
there a barbecue it's a big one yeah
they they overdo it i say
they've spoke out they were they would
they thought that meatballs were enough
and i said get one more package and then
we had like no yeah like 10 12 extra
meatballs you're not making the
meatballs ain't nothing wrong with it so
i'm not a cook but that night because i
haven't seen my family since christmas
and i really wanted to engage with them
i we all cooked it together okay which i
i don't normally do but i had very
menial tasks i chopped onions and sliced
garlic and then i made the balls of the
meat oh okay all right so you didn't
order don't worry like frozen meatballs
or anything no we made it from scratch
excellent yeah excellent now i assume
that she sent you home with those
meatballs in a container correct
will you be returning that container or
will you be keeping that container
okay
glass okay okay
it was plastic okay it was new they just
got a new set and this was i had never
seen this at the top there's this little
thing to open so it lets air out so that
when you're gonna put something on
that's really full which was the case in
that moment because they had one with
sauce
my brother-in-law went to put it down
and i said you're not going to make that
and sure enough it all spilled out and
then two seconds later he's like what is
this and he noticed you pop it so that
you can push it down the excess air
comes out the top and then yeah
same thing we're putting out so it was
new and so like for me i always return
the tupperware it hangs over my head and
i i i have i i'm very i have anxiety i
have ocd adhd all that [ __ ] and through
and through and that's diagnosed not
just me saying it okay and i will think
about that tupperware until i get it
back to her okay but you know i get that
i do have some tupperware and i don't
know where the hell it came from and i
did give it a tupperware that does not
get returned
so now i think i forgot so now i have
two sets of tupperware in the house i
have the one that's like not the
high-end plastic but like the plastic
like that yeah and then i have glass
that i that i don't give out that i keep
in the house sure the glass with the
clasps yeah it really keeps stuff fresh
you got the same set you got a few extra
days out of it it's worth the cost you
make up you make up the money why are
you preaching in a choir yeah yeah make
up for the course yeah
you clean the tupperware before you give
it back oh yeah what yeah
i got my gaddafi yeah this guy's not
putting gum underneath i don't know what
that means but who am i some bad fellow
said i'm hussein was notorious for that
never sent back a clean piece of
tupperware he got what was coming
as far as i'm concerned
it is a form of terrorism still at the
red sauce stained on the inside of a
[ __ ] you let it soak yeah that red
sauce is tough you gotta get in there
right away you soaked that throw a
little dawn in there man dude i've eaten
cereal out of bowls that had stains on
it yeah oh just taste a little bit of
oregano
what kind of soap are you working with
you brought that up
right in the kitchen in the kitchen yeah
um and then also hand soap what are you
doing in the bathroom sure give me a run
down i got you so
uh in the kitchen i've got we've tried
to go green
so i used to have like i i get that i
used to get like the myers or whatever
myers yeah and i would pour it into the
the glassware that's a classy move this
guy cares about details and i like that
so you're a meticulous guy
he knows what he's doing but i since
change and now i order this powder i
hear good things about this and and you
actually so there's no plastic it just
comes in the powder and you put the
powder in it and it like and you just so
the refills are not you're not buying
plastic over and over okay and for uh
the bathroom for for like [ __ ] like
facing anything
i do all sorts of i'm into skin care
i've recently gone into skin care so i'm
i'm doing all sorts of stuff i'm i'm
using toner i'm exfoliating i'm i'm
using i'm i'm i'm doing a mask hydrating
i got masks i got
a long way from staten island yeah yeah
no it doesn't take much you know it does
you don't you you could you
every the every man can can be uh
can do skin oh yeah i got the eye stuff
on right yeah yeah
or whatever it's called well since we
changed the forecast and getting
demolished in the comments
like i thought he was 72. what the hell
i assumed you didn't have that when you
were a kid you weren't no no no no
ivory or irish springer my grandparents
where i used to live downstairs at a
certain point and i still love i still
keep irish ring in the closet because i
still use it i think it's the best
smelling soap i've ever smelled but i do
buy like more like organic like i i'm a
soap guy
like if i'm on the road i'll pick up a
soap and a soy candle like nobody's
business and i bring them home and i and
i have a stash of soaps and candles
i burnt candles all around the house it
it really creates a nice ambiance even
when i'm home alone i like them
it settles me 100 yeah i want to throw
one out you know if you know this one
they're not a sponsor but we i love the
product beekman's 1802 have you heard of
this i feel like i do know goat milk
soap the arcadia smell yeah i think i
see it unbelievable beekman's 1802 beak
means 1802 do yourself a favor it's
[ __ ] they're absolutely fantastic the
the arcadia one the reason i love it it
has a reminder of coast soap remember
coast sure sure
literally take your [ __ ] skin off but
it's you smelled great okay yeah is it
is it a big block or no is that what the
big ones yeah they saw
it's like a brick yeah it's a huge brick
yeah i don't know i know real classy
real nice hotels
um yeah but i'll pay for i now pay for
shampoo and stuff like that well i use
head and shoulders really yeah i use it
at least once or twice a week just for
the dandruff i don't have yeah
preventative yeah okay and then in the
in betweens i i'll i'll like pay a
little extra money for the soap because
it goes a long way it does you know i i
say spend spend money on betting
footwear and experiences that's what i
say that's where i spend my money what
is the betting situation at the house
the betting's nice it's nice the bedding
is nice i did i'll tell you for the
first
man let me think about this
okay you're gonna this is crazy so the
for the i moved out of the house in 199
in 2000 1990 you know 2001.
made out of your parents house yeah so
20 so i was i was 24. okay
from that from i had the same mattress
for 24 years yeah i just got well from
my first match maybe not from from
newborn but my first mattress as like a
four-year-old or a five-year-old it was
a twin mattress twin and i slept in that
until it's 24. we moved but then i had
this really small room but it had a high
ceiling so my dad built like this like
little loft just for the mattress and it
fit up there so i would just i would
literally take a a-frame wooden ladder
out of my closet open it and go up the
ladder to go to bed every night he
didn't build you the ladder to go up now
what a union job what do you want to do
and then time and a half and then i
moved from then the first time i ever
moved out of my house i moved into like
a basement studio apartment and i didn't
know how long i was going to stay there
i left in a rush actually and um i left
in a huff and uh my dad as a gesture
goes and buys me a leather couch yet he
buys the three seater the love seat and
the single oh meanwhile it took up the
whole the hole yeah
exactly so i couldn't fit a mattress so
i was like all right the three-seater is
comfortable and it fits me i don't know
how long i'll be here nine years i slept
on that couch only couch for nine years
2001 to 2010 i slept on the couch did
not have a bed
that was my bed what was the reason that
you left in a huff can i ask a little
bit of a
a little bit of a friction okay friction
at home been there fair enough
did you get to keep the couch after that
or was it gone i
well when i moved to my next apartment i
gave those couches away to my cousins
and i bought new stuff very nice i'll
hand me down cap that you slept on for
nine years now yeah that's a tough
hand-me-down that one i think i tossed
okay but the single and the love the
single was like brand new yeah you know
the last year i gave away yeah kippy
babble babble lib babble lay baboo los
babble el babble i don't know if i'm
saying right but you got to get on babel
if you want to learn a new language yes
absolutely fantastic the easiest way to
learn a new language is with babble now
that you're a international man
traveling i'm an international
businessman now you're international of
course you're like my protege that's
right you gotta learn a new language
listen you can't go over there and start
acting like a bozo like hey where's the
burger king can't be doing that you got
to speak the language yes it's the best
learning app and they you know why
because they sold over 10 million
subscriptions look at that 15-minute
lessons to make it the perfect way to
learn a new language on the go uh other
learning apps use a.i for their lessons
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts not some
computer a robot doing it for you not
something good
red blooded people doing it for you uh
babble speech recognition therapy helps
you or technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent so you sound
like a native there you go you know it
sounds like a real french guy right now
when you purchase a three-month babble
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com use promo code garbage that's
babble b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code garbage babble language for life
skipping yes you like helix mattresses
like them love them sleep on them great
well i got a little something for you
what's that felix is uh also stepping
out of the realm of mattresses getting
into the furniture game with a little
company called all form all four
absolutely fantastic we got a couch
sitting right here comfortable
affordable easy to put up easy to set up
get it together t-bone get your feet off
my couch yeah uh it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you pick your fabric
you pick the color you pick what kind of
legs what color so if the size the shape
whole nine yards ah they got arm chairs
all the way to eight-seat sectionals
whether you're a one-part one-person
party you're hanging out with a crew
they got you covered all forms all form
sofas are delivered directly to your
home with fast free shipping right now
if you buy a sofa from a traditional
retailer take months to arrive they jam
you up yeah supply chain yup not what
all forms nope uh they were like we said
we got one over there t-bone's lounging
on it right now with his dirty muddy
skateboarder shoes all over it you're
grounded uh
[Laughter]
get down clean your room
they offer financing and flexible
payment plans so an amazing sofa is
never far away they even offer a forever
warranty literally forever to find your
perfect sofa go to all form.com garbage
and all former is offering 20 off off of
all orders for our listeners at
allforum.com garbage one more time all
form.com garbage i'm back to the show
yeah uh you were talking about
experiences on the road if you have to
choose one major chain food place like a
red lobster or tgi friday's what's green
if the club's closed it's late you're
not in a city where you can go get a
steakhouse or whatever
chain what are you doing or what do you
like to see a buffalo wild wings yeah i
i
if i have my choice i'm going to red
lobster whoa really okay
so red lobster the guys and i this guy
from the show uh-huh if for some reason
when we would celebrate from a young age
we'd go to red lobster okay we continued
that through our adulthood so when we
got the show we went to celebrate it
right last night yes
so the four are you looking pure trash i
love rolling into a red lobster how
about this when we got picked up for a
second season the president of true tv
at the time and his second in command
uh who citizens were fired send you
anywhere where do you want to go there
they were since fired but like and and
they and they they
the cat's out of the bag they were not
good but um
they were like let's go to dinner i'm
gonna go where do you want to go and we
were like we'll go to red lobster with
you and he's like red lobster what the
[ __ ] are you talking about and they're
like like that's where we go yeah so
that's that's how we do it like we're
granted we know what it's about but we
keep the tradition we go to red lobster
he's like you don't want to go to he
goes per se which is like
one of the almost high end
and we're like no we'll go to red
lobsters they have cheesy biscuits there
then shut up biscuits from the sea so we
went to the
time square red lobster and you know
when you wait for a table they give you
the they give you the beeper
ahead of going with him we went there
the beeper there is a lobster claw that
lights up red whoa we went asked for a
table walked out stole it
put it in a velvet box a very fancy
velvet box with like a satin bow shipped
it to his office and he opened it and it
was the buzzer waiting to go to red
lobster
these guys are fun
i got a story here a joke
i got a story so so he's like all right
we'll go he ends up reserving a private
room for us so it's the four of us and
the two of them right i can't believe
they have that at that redlast i know
it's just the basement but still
you're next to the boxes of sodas
but it's all right
you're eating the seafood gumbo in
madame tussauds
it was the loading dock
[Laughter]
he's not there he gets there ends up
getting there like 20 30 minutes late so
we're like all right so we didn't like
the guy right so we get the waiter ahead
of time we go listen we don't like this
guy he's paying do me a favor we want to
order everything even if we don't say it
to you or this this this this it's just
bring it out when i tell you i want a
lobster i'm going to say i want a hot
bring me the heaviest lops do you have
for all of us so he's like i got it i
got it so we eat the whole freaking meal
at the end of the meal the bill came it
was like a cvs receipt
he opened it i have your phone number we
saw his face it was trifold and he like
this
and he looked it was seven hundred
dollars
[Laughter]
red lobster
seven hundred dollars
and then my buddy take that suit
where are you gonna get 700 bucks for a
buddy
joke's on you
and then he was like i mean he was going
to put the car down and like you know
but he he couldn't be like how is this
possible so he just like we saw him like
what the [ __ ] and then my buddy murray
he he he took out of it he goes i have
this if you need it he had printed a
five dollar coupon from this and he cut
it and he just slid it over and the guy
goes oh [ __ ] your coupon
well we spent another 50 i get 10 off
somebody got room for
dessert red lobster yeah okay
okay i love it where would where would
be nice i'm not adverse to other places
of course i'm just saying it's
fundamental it's going to happen
of course what would be like a nice
dinner out for the family when you were
a kid where would you go oh no place
really no place big we didn't go out to
dinner a lot at all actually really yeah
someplace incidental like the mall like
ground round okay well if you know what
that is
something like that i'm out of business
that burger smell
that like that like almost a1 burger
smell that hits you when you get out of
the car in the parking lot yeah i would
float into that place as a little kid
free popcorn they played the movies on
the wall we also there's a place called
farrell's which if you look that up it
was like for a kid it was awesome
because it was like an old-timey it was
a it's like a burger joint it was like
old-timey it had like a whole concession
stand candy it was like it was from the
50s the guys wore those like hats and
then yeah the what do you call it like
the acapella
yeah
like that like that foam
top hat or whatever yeah i know exactly
what you're talking about yeah yeah
like um barbershop quartet exactly right
yeah what about the vacations when you
were a kid would you do any of them i i
never was on a plane until i was 18 on
my own wow
we were supposed to go to disney world
when i was little and i got the flu so i
was told
so i was told but we did drive sick as a
dog
what are you talking about i feel great
you got mickey ears on
lotion it was like eminem's mom she was
like just made me believe i was sick
okay and uh
we uh we would go to uh like great gorge
in vernon valley new jersey like that
was like a resort up there okay a ski
resort and a summer resort everything so
we would drive and do that okay like
that was like the pokemon
pokemon go to the pokemon yeah we would
do drives drive but i i never flew
anywhere i never was yeah when was the
first time you went out of the country
first time i went down the country i was
i think probably uh always if this
counts it was mexico 95. okay it's not
bad yeah new mexico was like you know
college like friendship
but like proper proper probably london
at 21. all right yeah there you go too
shabby do you have a dave and buster's
card in your wallet right now by any
chance i don't but i do have
two cards that i don't know if they're
still active but they had a balance
uh in my class my drawer in my closet at
home
because they have a balance what am i
going to do yeah i even took pictures of
them so that if i ever you can i don't
go to dave and buses i should say that i
i've only gone a couple times in my life
but one time we went out to filming we
took the whole crew and we got
shit-faced and we bought cards for
everyone so just did that yeah yeah yeah
we just did it in syracuse it was fun of
[ __ ] oh did you go this one has the the
pac-man that's like it's four players at
the same time it's the screen is like
the size of that wall oh no and you play
against each other so there's four
pac-man if you bump into someone you
bump them out of the way it's like
competitive package i forget what it's
called oh my god we didn't leave the
machine i didn't leave the machine i
even looked it up to get it like from my
home but it's it's unreasonably priced
oh i feel like i could imagine
what was the biggest purchase you made
when you when when like say that second
season you guys get that check was there
an irresponsible purchase that you made
or is that not there was no check in
that second season
it took a while that's season seven i
could have i seriously could have worked
at target and made the same money the
first thing they started delivering
[Laughter]
back in playing bumper cars and stuff
when you when when you first hit it what
i would i get um
or anything like that i bought a used
bmw okay it's all right it was
29 000. all right pay cash did you
finance that um no i financed it okay
yeah that's reasonable yeah
that was a big that was a big thing
i'm trying to think of i mean really if
i bought anything
really really big i i don't really
i don't really splurge on big things
again i do want
a big shoe guy too betting shoe and an
experience
always talking about how many pairs of
sneakers would you say you have uh
300 maybe 300 250 all in the setup with
like what i'm imagining like in the in
the closet and i don't have a big enough
place i have like about 70 75 pairs in
my closet i have about another like
maybe
30 upstairs and then like another like
150 in storage or something like that
holy [ __ ] so you have a storage unit
yeah not because not for the sneakers
it's because uh i just have too much
[ __ ] yeah and i'm move i'm gonna move
eventually and i needed like an interim
space okay i just i've only had it for
the past year all right do you have any
like super rare ones like some jordan
one crazy [ __ ] yeah i got some rare ones
i got uh i got those back to the future
mags i have uh those things are nuts
yeah the tom sacks mars yard a mars 2.0
i know if you know those or
i have dude i don't know [ __ ] about
sneakers those are the only two i know
oh really
chicago off-whites i have some i have
some big pairs what's the most you've
ever spent on a pair of sneakers a
single pair oh i don't know um
a grand two grand three grand maybe
around three but the ones i bought at
three
are about six now yeah gotcha and i
haven't won bitcoin yeah it's like and
i've i've traded and i've sold sneakers
and i've made money that's all yeah like
if i make money on a trade or a sale
i'll buy another pair with that money
it's not like i'm not i'm not just
spending i got you yeah i don't just
spend three thousand on sneakers sure
yeah do you go so most of my sneakers
are regular you know
early do you go to those like sneaker
things i don't go to the cons but i do
go like to
you know what happened like it used to
be a it used to be different the whole
landscape of sneaker like sneakers has
changed and now it's all online and it's
automated and there's bots and there's
all this [ __ ] you used to have to know
someone or wait online
and you could get that pair like a hype
pair for retail and then you me it was a
big deal yeah now i like i have a guy
and i work with him you have a shoe guy
i got him from burt kreischer
it's everybody's shoe guy i give him a
shout out all the time angelo blando god
bless the kids love them
okay have you ever owned a switchblade
comb
i have one right now really swear to god
on you no
dude do you think i would have said i
have i would have just took it out
zip
[Applause]
could you imagine i pulled it out and
combed my hair right now you would have
to shut this whole place down that's
insane i wrote that question two years
ago when we started and i've never used
it on anybody and i know i do because i
have this junk box in my ba in my spare
bedroom and i and i it's it's in there
in the yellow box still like a yellow
box yeah
and i recently went through there and i
saw it and i was like you don't you
don't throw that out yeah i don't throw
that out you don't know when one day one
day it will fulfill its role good head
of hair fun guy he's got that today was
the day i had that [ __ ] for 20 years
today was the day and i blew it
come on
uh any chinese stars num chucks anything
like that 100 yeah i had them all
fireworks
fireworks i had yeah i didn't
hoard them but we did ride our bikes
down to st john's avenue when there was
a guy that sold him out of his
garage nice and uh he's the neighborhood
guy
[Laughter]
chinese star they used to go to the um
we had this thing called the big apple
bazaar it was like one of those uh flea
markets flea market yeah that's where
every kid got yeah
yeah flea market saturday mornings or
whatever 100 they got them there and
then i had nunchucks but they were like
um foam the padded ones yeah every day
they were good they were a good time but
i went out with those i loaded up i went
out and we walked around and made sure
everything was cool
how'd you like a slight bruise on your
forearm
tough guy
those i would throw yeah yeah yeah those
i would throw like just they wouldn't do
anything bb gun
i didn't have one my dad had one shot a
kid one time really okay let's pause
here
let's get this
station identification
for weather on the twos with toby
what was that situation why would your
dad pull the bb gun um eric so he was
the superintendent of the apartments
that we lived in at the time he had
multiple jobs okay i was getting into
that growing up he was yeah so he had
two full-time jobs city job and super
full-time yeah so you guys lived there
for free yeah well yes yeah he did but
then when we got divorced we did my mom
and he moved and paid he moved in the
other building and paid paid to live and
we live for free holy [ __ ] your parents
got divorced and they lived in the
building next to each other yeah that's
staten island right yeah that's about as
staten island as again yeah yeah that's
like also the dad's the super and a
[ __ ] sanitation
yeah we had so the kid man he had your
mom by the balls i think
you like this free apartment
holy [ __ ] i just know that he told me he
told me the story one time so he had an
office and there was one kid and he was
walking his dog and this kid everybody
hated this kid he was like like a teen
and uh he was like people just he was a
piece of [ __ ] the bad kid yeah so my dad
written every time my dad was just gonna
like you know i don't think he thought
it was gonna hurt him at all and i and i
think he was not gonna aim for his like
like i don't think he was gonna pierce a
bb gun sure but i know he told me he
cracked the door open it was like one of
those pump ones and he he put stuck the
nozzle out so the door was cracked it's
like a brinks truck
and my cousin who was my whole family
and everybody was like on the
on the staff of the building like
maintenance nice one was my cousin what
was my grandpa you know like all that
stuff so
my cousin was in there and my dad stuck
honey and he just pulled it and the kid
was like oh
and he just screamed and hit him like in
the face or whatever and then he he ran
and got his mother and the mother came
back and she went straight to the office
like one moment she's like somebody shot
my son with this bb gun oh what my dad
was like let's go
and they went walking with him
i'm gonna have a hard time finding
myself the case was never solved
the witnesses all disappeared
i hope there's a statute
what if there wasn't there's no statue
of baby like that gets hold off 76 years
old
where were you june 4th
1991 now do you guys after he does that
does he take the bb gun to the verrazano
and throw it over
wrap it in a blanket file the serial
number off real quick
find the prince of a dead man on there
[Laughter]
what about you any injuries as a kid you
break anything um i didn't break
anything um
that was my clinton fame for a very long
time no broken bones never broke no
stitches no cavities wow no cavities
yeah yeah even now now i oh man you got
a nice set of white chompers on it
exactly it's a shame to say this but a
couple of years ago i ended up getting
about three or four cavities first time
in my life but uh there's this new thing
now where you can't even you you
wouldn't even know oh yeah the new way
it doesn't pull it doesn't matter
yeah yeah they're not melt they're not
[ __ ] yeah so i do have a few now but
you don't understand what a fall from
grace that was for me
i i would lead with it
[Laughter]
but i i did get hit by a car when i was
four
yeah i was right we've talked about it
we've been on record getting hit by cars
never traveling doing something you
shouldn't have been doing probably so so
i was with my dad we were playing
frisbee and it was right it was like
down the block from his office from the
apartments we we uh we lived at and it
was it was what do you call those those
posts vw posts vw yeah like like like a
little post like yeah they're like like
no no no no no like like um oh like a
catering hall vfw
post i'm like it was like a v like a
tour egg it's like an old cereal company
we're going to beat those nazis
vw post cereal twice the brand
show hitler we mean business
with vw
man i'm sweating
i'm getting in the heat we got you the
hot seat yeah
you're talking about guns and statues
getting sweaty jesus christ let me take
this off
um so yeah so so we were playing frisbee
so there was that was down the box so it
was closed so the parking lot was 100
empty and it was all one way in for cars
otherwise it was gated later on for many
years that's where we played roller
hockey okay a big parking lot so i go in
there with my dad and uh the front gate
is closed there's only one back gate
open behind the thing small gate and i'm
talking this thing is huge like you
could play like that's on both sides
yeah that kind of thing not like uh not
like in the suburbs like what would be
the parking lot of supermarkets sure but
uh like a church parking lot yeah yeah
yeah i gotcha and my dad is only us in
there and we're throwing this it was a
coca-cola for his bill i'll never forget
he was throwing it back and forth and
then somebody's walking down the street
my dad knew so he went to the chain link
the gate it was high and had like um
barbed wire yes thank you so much follow
me around please
he sent you out for a long one so you
could talk to his friend yeah there you
go sally
so he went through he threw it and it
did that thing the bend yeah and i went
over there and i went to go walk to get
it and i saw a station wagon had entered
from the other side now i'm the only
object in the loft
so in my head even at four or five i was
like i'm good he sees me this guy's
gotta stink there i'm walking to it he's
driving to it i get to the frisbee he's
still driving at me i look down and i go
to pick it up i will never forget this i
go to pick it up i see him coming i pick
it up i drop it and i'm like should i
get should i and i went to pick it up
again woke up i just woke up in my dad's
arms he was running to the car oh so it
was like probably probably like four or
five minutes later jesus yeah and my dad
actually recently i didn't know this he
recently told me that he freaked out and
he started like he wanted to get the guy
out of the car and he was like punching
the car and everything and the guy would
like wouldn't get out of here i'll get
my bb gun
and then my dad's friend was like sal
sal stop punching the car
stop punching a car oh my dad grabbed me
and then he was running i woke up he was
running and then we went to the hospital
and i had you know bumps and bruises it
was like i got battered with some soft
nunchucks
but somebody who knows how to use them
yeah what happened to the guy in the
station wagon um we sued him but it
wasn't a lot of money i got five
thousand dollars i couldn't touch it
till i was 18. that's your dad gave it
to you yeah oh what a [ __ ] great guy
what do you mean that's awesome what do
you mean it doesn't have to it's family
money no my mom would have [ __ ] now
she she would have funneled that money
yeah yeah yeah i had a buddy that's got
200 and he got ran over when we were
skateboarding got 250 000 that's real
money we were like 12. that's insane
like i can't touch until i was 18. we
were like keeping him in a bubble until
he turned 18. that's it but you keep
this kid alive and we're all on easy
street mine was 12 about 12 when i got
yeah 12 000. really so you knew the
whole time growing up that you had that
weight and i had to wait
i would have been running my mouth
wait till i get my station wagon money
you pose those why don't i told my first
girlfriend i was going to use it for
ring money
[Laughter]
babe just waiting i got the station
wagon from the frisbee accident
that's like a shitty version of west
side story just wait till my wait till
my wake up my station wagon money
[Laughter]
we'll get off this goddamn island i'll
tell you it's like what's his name from
uh from goodfellas the pittsburgh pigs i
got my station wagon money coming
sally that's all we have
good lord
um okay would you consider yourself a
fan of the tv show deadliest catch
no
really never seen it how many times
maybe incidentally like
i couldn't i know it's about the fishing
boats right yeah yeah but not
appointment viewing in the volcano no no
i never i've maybe seen perfectly an
episode but okay how many times have you
seen the town
once you got ben affleck yep yeah once
boston
bank robbing somebody's bending me
i saw it in the theater toby get this
guy out of here i saw i told you get my
bb gun
i saw it in the theater i saw in the
theater not a theater all right all
right i'll give you
no i never had a pool my whole life
never had a pool uh there was one for
the apartment buildings oh really yeah
so i had i had the pool when we lived
there but uh personally i've never had a
pool that's pretty nice well actually
right now right now as of
two years ago my dad has a pool he moved
to jersey okay and uh and he has that's
the progression right it's like brooklyn
to staten island staten island yeah
that's what a lot of people like
generational you gotta yeah
okay you own a pair of crocs
i did i don't right now you own a pair
of uggs i do not what you're thinking
they're for the haters
they're like
they're like proper snow boots not like
lindsay lohan's or something gotcha yeah
okay um not fur and stuff uh do you know
karate
um i don't but i took karate in eighth
grade for about six months yes i was a
white belt uh double black tip iron fist
okay that's when i checked out it was
about about six months and my mom was
like i'm not going to pay for this if
you're not going to take it seriously
what's that was it like sensei glenn
he's dead now sensei glenn no way glenn
was a good sensei
was it like a proper dojo or was it like
a strip mall it was at the ceo that we
played basketball in the catholic youth
center yeah yeah yeah
cy cyl see why i'm messing up all my
acronyms today
uh have you ever cut the sleeves off a
hoodie
no okay you have magnets on your
refrigerator right now
not on this one
i have one magnet on my on my um
uh dishwasher okay that i just got like
he looked to me to be like i don't know
this one
don't leave me hanging here right now
but from the place i just moved from it
was covered head to toe
but i i upgraded my fridge and i have
like an adult fridge like now a little
bit like stainless steel we're talking
stainless steel sub z yeah why i just
feel bad to put the magnets on it okay
but my other one was a frigidaire white
yeah yeah they hovered out there it had
it was covered with every school photo
of my knee everything i even bought
those stupid poetry things you know what
i mean like the word the word thing yeah
yeah well i mean i had it in college i
threw it on the fridge and that was on
that fridge for that many years
what's the what's the oven is it a
viking uh it's a wolf is that good yeah
it's it's
i never heard of it i upgraded you know
like just recently i like i bought a
place my first place ever bought about
five years ago okay yeah yeah yeah
um you have name brand luggage
now i get my luggage like marshall's
whatever i have it's it might be
samsonite but it was like compare at
79.99 yeah it was like it wasn't
anything special
i'm sorry i did get luggage as a gift
that's like a fly oh some nice luggage
from my agent
probably yeah yeah away yeah
i'm looking at wolf oven ranges right
now does does yours have the flat top on
it
the griddle uh no it's six six range six
burners yeah cooking over there it's
doing all right
that's a lot of meatballs
i know i know but i don't i don't cook
like that so what's the number on the
wolf
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
mine was
12.5 plus tax
no that's surprising that their fridge
was like 11. yeah but the wolf was like
i think five or six those are expensive
and i went in hard on the uh i built i
built it out so i went in hard because
when you resell i'm told that's
the bathrooms and kitchens are a big big
deal
people look for those buzzwords so i
just wanted something that would last me
a long time and then have hold uh value
when i'm gonna sell again very sensible
very sensible guy yeah smart guy um do
you hang your t-shirts or do you fold
them fold
like that i can't hang it'll ruin it
yeah yeah boxers briefs uh it's the
boxer briefs excellent yeah socks ankle
socks high socks uh summer ankle and
no-show
rest of the year mid ankle nice so
you're on top of all that stuff on top
two sock drawers how many too many socks
i gotta wear to socks how many suits do
you own
uh
not a lot two and two sport coats maybe
two two coats name brand on the suits um
one is
j crew and one is uh
uh who's that guy versace
who's that guy
it's like um
chemical no but it's it's kind of like
okay it's maybe from he's maybe from
london yeah tony baker little flash
baker baker baker ted baker yeah all
right that's respectable i got it at uh
saks off off
yeah
more than a decade ago it's still the
one i used off sack down the street from
saks i've been there yeah yeah
um
did you ever wear your high school class
ring
nah okay uh when i got it yeah yeah
flash it a little bit yeah like at
school
if you get takeout or something
delivered to the house do you open the
bag or do you just rip the bag
what do you do do you just rip the bag
open if they staple it i'm ripping it
open okay if it's folded nicely i'll
keep it as this now will you plate that
food or will you just eat it out of
containers it's it's anybody's guess
it depends on my mood i've plated and i
and i've eaten out of the container more
so than not if it's manageable out of
the container i'll keep it in the
container okay uh but if it's like if
it's if it's going to be awkward or it's
going to cut i mean i can't get it
yeah then i'm going to and i'm going to
take it off and put it on the plate you
do a real christmas tree at the house so
you got a fake one right now i have a
fake i've done real
so my five years in this house my first
year was a real
and it's just too much the needles are
too much they're everywhere i gotta the
tree i have now i'm in love with it i'm
in love with it is it white
it is not but i love a white tree
italians love a white stripe
i got it at costco it's it's pre-lit
that thing is 10 feet tall i never have
to shape it it comes out of the box it's
up in five sec
this morning this morning
wait this morning i [ __ ] you not at 9 30
in the morning i took my tree down i
brought it to the storage ah this
morning what yes i used i usually go to
sometimes even more midfield i'm a big
christmas guy whoa oh yeah [ __ ] well
you're still turning it on at night like
when you're out every night sitting
watching tv i'm not going to not do that
yeah it's there
what's a guy damn what's up come home my
girl would be sitting watching
television and it wasn't lit up and i'd
be like what are you doing what are you
a sociopath you're having great joy
right behind you be having the joy
you could turn it from white lights to
colored lights everything oh man that's
something else ever been to an air show
yes have you ever seen a crash in an air
show no okay blue angels nice that's
good mountain road the blue angels um
have you ever rented a u-haul truck yes
wait can i ask you guys a question
are these off the dome are you asking
like is this a standard like no it's new
it's there's a couple
how do you keep
how do you how are you able to find
mourinho because we're [ __ ] [ __ ]
trash man i don't know we're living this
way i told you i put the gum on this
thing
he gave me [ __ ] for it it's an
unbelievable feat though because you
guys how many episodes are you guys
there's two hundred of our that's insane
and you had a line of questioning for
200 episodes and like there's not we
find the good ones and the ones that
yeah there's a mismatch for sure i i
didn't mean to uh no no no but like the
comb one i literally i think i i don't
think we've ever used the comb the
switchblade comb oh i do have a comb in
my pocket no i know what i'm saying
oh that's even weirder what the [ __ ] of
a comb babe i got a comb
i leave the house with chapstick a
writing utensil and a cookie it's pretty
good i'll give you that it's only
because i grew my beard out a little bit
and because i have a floppy [ __ ]
right now and sometimes it looks really
thick
but i missed the last question
[Laughter]
u-haul truck yeah i rented one yeah
yeah
i like how that's the only guy you all i
got an account
i got it but no there's a lot of
questions that people watch one
but no a lot of peop they want to know
like different comedians how they feel
on different things you know what i mean
here's a big one growing up was it uh
hellman's mayonnaise or was it miracle
whip hellmann's good see there you go do
you brush your teeth in the shower
no you pee in the shower i have okay i
don't make it a habit all right
if you have a tub catches me off guard
i have a tub yeah you have a tub you
have a tub in the shower or a separate
tub separate
glass doors
yes rainfall shower head yes this kid's
all right yeah
this kid's doing it local boys
right i got the jets which i never use
really yeah i was like do it i took my
first big i'm just gonna do it up do it
put the jets in i put the handheld the
rain the jets never work they get on
they shoot like a fire hose they slap
against the back of the wall they're
just they're
they're hitting parts i don't need
it but i do i did put a steam shower in
there too nice and five years i've used
it four or five times but when i use it
it's a real hum dinger i put the i put
the uh essential oils on there i get it
smelling nice do when i have a cold nice
he likes to take care of himself i do
like that now let me ask you this when
you got these new uh appliances or even
when you got the house everybody comes
over right you give them the tour they
walk around yes sally it is that the
other thing yeah i host a lot a lot you
do yeah my whole family friends host all
the time did you do who is it usually at
your house is where everyone's coming
yeah so thanksgiving was eight hours
thanksgiving do i do christmas okay but
i also host like
birthdays this stuff the other gotcha
friends and family go to south yeah yeah
yeah i have it at sales but usually
catered or cooking um
more so than not cooking okay but
catering also nice depends on the
depends sometimes a mixture i like it
yeah very classy i don't again i don't
cook yeah but
i think i only got a couple more here i
have a real quick one have you ever been
to a dinner where someone paid with a
black card
and or do you have a black card
i don't have one but i have been at a
dinner when someone paid one you have an
amex though right yeah dynamics you have
a capital one card
i think it's i think it's it's it's like
done i think i haven't didn't cancel it
but they were like if you're not gonna
use it yeah what are we doing here mr
volcano we could use your business
that's a nice wallet
yeah you care about the numbers
of course yeah yeah what are you doing
you're pulling this out
we're in 4k
they'll be still i'll be stealing the
water [ __ ]
can you catch that
this one's fun this one's like the oh we
got one of them yeah
that one's fun it makes you feel like
it's a lot but it's just
it's just a little heavier no they know
what they're doing it's just like
tinfoil on the outside
[Laughter]
we'll all be having wolf rangers pretty
soon hold on
put it on sal's [ __ ] ah man keep butter
on the counter you put it in the fridge
uh fridge okay salted or unsalted
both really yeah gentlemen bagel bites
or pizza rolls
bagel bites if you had to have a frozen
pizza what's it gonna be
it's a very good question
also what'd you grow up with what i grew
up with was eliot of course he's 90s
kids yeah i grew up with ilios uh
right now i'll get like uh
i don't know what she gets from the
supermarket it's like one of those organ
like it's not it's not california pizza
kitchen's big amy's puts out a pretty
decent it's probably amazing amy's does
it does it good but i'll also what i'll
do is i'll go to like a place like
because i had i just got rid of it but i
had a little apartment in brooklyn near
table 87 and lose those and all those
places and some of those those guys they
do the like the freeze-dried pizza sure
and then i'll get i'll go get that nice
you ever read the
yes really yeah a few times i do shadows
i got a you got your royalty over here
you got it in there yeah nice my best
friend's dad knows the guy i wouldn't
mention any names
i didn't mention anything
my best friend steve from growing up
from mulberry lake
do you currently own a drone
no were you a fan of the a-team growing
up yes yeah you weren't
talking about it shut up he's been on an
eight hey team bin they put him on
peacock i've been crushing them we we
were uh we're we're doing for the first
time ever the beginning of the opening
credits of the show sure in the next
season and so now we're having these
creative conversations about it and it's
been kicked around to
to mimic the a-team opening holy [ __ ]
we used to do that all the time we would
[ __ ] we'd say the lines we'd all jump
on the bed i had the van
you oh man
that thing was unbelievable how did they
not get caught the most conspicuous
looking vape yeah they're driving all
over the country
good writers i don't know what do you
mean
um
let's say you're going to a dinner party
at a friend's house right you know we
use version a lot let's say you're going
to versions oh my versus my
he's the best um you're going to a party
at versie's barber i've done it i've
done it of course yeah i know that's why
i'm you're taking a bottle of wine or a
gift for you know sure what do you what
would you do a bottle of wine sure how
what are you dropping on that bottle of
wine yeah i'm going i'm going i'm doing
it i'm going to do especially with him
he knows yeah yeah well i just you know
what you know what sucks when you do it
and you have no idea if they know when
they just throw it on the thing
i guess they're making sangria with it
yeah that [ __ ] toasted out in the pan
ah perfect i just put the mussels on the
stove
i mean if it's if i'm going to someone
like if it's like they're they're making
a nice dinner or it's like a more of a
like a like a holiday or something like
that if i'm just going like a party you
know i've got a regular bottle or
whatever i'll usually bring like liquor
but i'm bringing a wine not to a 50 50
to 100. cool okay yeah very very very
good yeah you cut your burger in half
when you eat it no you put when you put
the burger back down you put it upside
down
so you would bite and then drop it like
that to keep the structural integrity of
said birth oh i understand
oh
[Laughter]
i think i usually put it back the way it
is but meticulously okay he just winked
at me
favorite gatorade
um it now i gotta go with the z the g
the zero sugar the short calorie one of
course and it's that light the light
purple
okay
i forget what it's called yeah but
growing up
i gotta go just uh traditional classic
yeah yeah when we were kids all they
really had was orange yellow yellow and
red yeah you have gatorade gum when you
were a kid yes they did that was the
greatest yeah ever
um have you ever been to a bikini car
wash
i threw one
what
but not me no not that
show i'm just gonna i'm just gonna close
my book real quick
i did we did car washes as kids to like
make money
we also would go to the supermarket and
ask people if they wanted to carry their
bags from the from the door to the car
wow because they wouldn't let the when
we were little they had up steel poles
so you couldn't get the parts out and so
like you just size up somebody if you
saw like a nikko woman you'd be like
this might turn into a finskey yeah
yeah
but uh yeah so car wash no not yet no no
okay not on your own of course you did
it for comedy purposes yes yes yes can
you play chess no
can you name three classical composers
sure
okay you want to do that
you'll be right now
maybe you want to throw it right now get
back to you in two days because i can do
it for you right now
mozart bach and galileo galileia
steve perry
you got bon jovi
all right you got the boss
uh uh first concert
my first concert was bon jovi wow bon
jovi new jersey tour june 29 1989 at
giant stadium they filmed the video to
lay your hands on me at the thing you're
in there billy squire and skid row
opened for him god damn i'm in that we
sat i'm in that
i'm up in there we sat
a few rows from the literal back top
wall and my mom went between that and
the station wagon money you were doing
all right
i'll tell you that right now
holy [ __ ] any paintings of your family
no there's a pain to give me but let me
explain that oh my god true tv did an ad
campaign where they put our faces in
famous old paintings and as a gift they
sent me the oil painting with like a
gilded frame
i'm not a psychopath i can't hang this
up in my house so i put in like a back
room because and then like sometimes
people come over and i have to be like
i'm not a psychopath
i sent this this is a goof i'll probably
tell you i'm gonna hang it i wanted it
to be bigger to be honest
but no no no we don't have any paintings
but don't delete the painting directly
in the eye yeah right now uh will you
get in the express lane with too many
items
yeah we'll do that
like what are we talking i'm not gonna
no you're not gonna abuse i'm gonna do
it so that's if you're in a pinch i'm
gonna do it so that someone at a glance
can't challenge me
and i know how to position stuff in the
basket too i'm not an [ __ ] yeah
okay okay you sleep with the tv on yes i
do sleep with a fan on you sure really i
mean i would i mean not right i have and
i would not every night right now
i have a little uh a purifier too nana
ooh very nice not a purify yeah yeah
yeah no no purifier okay what's the
vacuum cleaner at the house is it a
dyson it is yeah of course it is of
course yes this guy's got [ __ ] this
guy got a wolf ring he's not rocking a
dice
how good is that that is the that is the
pre that is the top of the line air
dryer dude every time i do it i go that
the accelerator is not too bad either
the accelerator is good but it's second
to the outside of the giant hold on
we're talking about soul mate are we
talking about hand dryers in public
places
that we are doing welcome to the show
i i my date my attitude changes when i
get one of the dysons out in the
bathrooms i was thinking that we were on
the road this week and i was just like
it just yeah everything's because then
the handle is not wet everything's
better and it's and it's stronger and it
works faster it's more efficient that
accelerates ergonomics
yeah uh the dyson i got the ball the
animal but i'll tell you something to
change your life get the stick as well
okay it's handheld it charges it's light
it has the attachments you use a dust
buster but you get the steps with it it
has a swivel so you get right under the
couch with it it's for quick cleaning it
has a turbo boost uh setting it'll
change your life and you're doing you
have a cleaning lady or no well i have
someone come like once a month but
you're in my i i do i don't mind
cleaning and i do all the in-between
cleaning really yeah man it's [ __ ]
fantastic if i have you know if and when
i have time but i do do it sure okay um
if you if you cracked open an egg yeah
and there was two yolks in there are you
still eating it
no
really what are you talking about yeah i
never heard such a thing really i'll
call my local authority
i don't know what that is you've never
seen that double double oh i would have
a lot of questions i i did it i was
making scrambled eggs one time it
happened with two eggs so i had i
cracked two eggs there was four it was
like back to back oh that's a bad boy i
know man
i still think about i ate it
that chicken was on drugs yeah i still
think about it that's weird it's crazy
yeah double yolks oh no all right we
gotta wrap it up yeah we gotta wrap it
up sal this has been [ __ ]
unbelievable so much fun this has been
the most fun i've had on my podcast i
think in my life
you're hard to hear folks buddy thank
you so much sal volcano going to be at
the beacon theater may 14th get pickies
at salvoconno.com you got anything else
you want the folks out there to know uh
march 11th the ryman uh and then i have
a tour dates all over so if you go to
savilecanoncomedy.com
they're all up there and i don't know
when this is coming out but the pre-sale
for the beacon theater starts tomorrow
so i'm assuming this will be out yeah
yeah yeah so uh yeah that's i mean the
beacon is just blew my mind so [ __ ]
first time solo headlining in new york
city so i just want to sell the [ __ ] out
of that thing i love that absolutely
fantastic congratulations salva connor
one of the best hundred percent staten
island garbage yeah crash through and
throughout we [ __ ] love you at the
dump
i knew it coming in i mean
i lived next to the largest dump in the
world you realize red lobster's not
going to leave you alone
so we heard you stole the thing from it
kevin what do you got for him uh chad
we're on the road we're all over the
[ __ ] country get some tickets uh
cameron comedy on all social media
subscribe the whole nine yards thank you
so much for listening gang we love you
we'll see you next week peace